à
notre histoire commence dans les années
1920 les héros victorieux de la bataille
de vittorio veneto défilent dans les
rues d'un pays en fait
cependant l'italie est déçu par les
conditions du traité de versailles
profitant du climat d'insatisfaction
générale benito mussolini se fait le
porte-parole des protestations
populaires
derrière les ihm et les chansons de
circonstance
auxquels s'ajoute un programme populiste
l'ombre du duce s'étendra bientôt sur
toute la péninsule
grâce à ces images champêtre les
cameramen au service du régime veulent
donner l'idée d'un pays gardien des
valeurs de l'italie éternel mais bêcher
labour est fauché battre le grain
travail à la ferme sont toujours
synonymes d'une vie harassante et
misérable
c'est l'époque des grands départs
nocturne les coureurs s'élancent de
turin en direction de gênes qui paraît
alors si loin
nous sommes au temps des pionniers et
malgré les efforts des organisateurs
il n'y a rien d'étonnant à ce qu'un
participant se trompe de route de jour
comme de nuit entraînant parfois dans
son sillage certains de ses concurrents
bien que l'on doive se soumettre aux
saluts fascistes alors obligatoire
le cyclisme est un sport libre et
populaire
à
en 1927 c'est alfredo binda surnommé le
héros de l'équipe legnano qui est le
vainqueur du tour d'italie après avoir
remporté douze étapes sur 15
ce sport durée extrêmement pratiqué sur
route par des protagonistes appartenant
aux couches sociales modestes
n'intéresse pas réellement le régime
seule la ligne d'arrivée permet aux
politiciens de mettre en valeur son
image devant une foule en liesse
canaliser comme dans les stades lors des
matches de football ou des spectacles de
gymnastique le 21 mai 1933
alfredo binda remporte son 5ème giraud
franchissant la ligne d'arrivée devant
des dignitaires
tandis que binda champions à cellules
s'exprime en renouant avec la figure du
lutteur italique les fascistes portant
aéro bicyclette et coureurs ceux-ci
plainte enthousiasme notre le visage
débonnaire de l'italie mais plus pour
très longtemps
de l'autre côté des alpes en france
terre d'immigration des italiens le
cyclisme est une sorte de fête populaire
où les coureurs et les spectateurs
fraternisent de vendée buffet improvisé
en 1938 bartali en pleine forme physique
a pour mission de représenter l'italie
dans le prestigieux tour de france
dans ce pays qui n'est pas encore un
ennemi les femmes jouissent d'une
certaine liberté qui leur permet de ne
pas être reléguées au foyer
l'italien bartali comme l'appellent les
présentateurs français remplit
consciencieusement sa mission grimpeur
d'exception ils dominent tous ses
adversaires dans les côtes
casse-cou il les pulvérise littéralement
dans les descentes
déjà doté du titre de meilleur grimpeur
bartali endosse le maillot jaune jusqu'à
paris
un exploit lejeune fast aux copies et
son grand admirateur
il participe au tour du piémont en 1939
où il rivalise avec son idole copie
perds la course de peu le grand gino
incrédule observe cet inconnu et le fer
engagé dans son équipe pour le giro de
l'année suivante et il gagne à 20 ans
son premier tour d'italie
juin 1940 le duce déclare l'entrée en
guerre de l'italie n'étaient pas
d'accompagnateur
onze jours après la victoire de coppi au
giro et dix jours après la déclaration
de guerre ce sont d'autres bicyclette
qui se dirige vers menton et nice côté
italien les moyens sont dérisoires les
morts nombreux les soldes un manque
d'entraînement et reçoivent peu d'être
de la population ce qui tranche avec
enthousiasme de leurs commandants
et
la guerre est finie l'heure de la
reconstruction est arrivé en 1945 un
célèbre anti fasciste arturo toscanini
dirige la scala de milan reconstruite
après les bombardements
milan san remo l'événement cycliste du
printemps
copie ne peut pas ne doit pas la perdre
elle constitue le nouveau lancement de
sa carrière interrompue par la guerre
son destin on dépend à travers un
territoire divisé par des rivalités
régionales
fausto cours sur son territoire avant de
rouler vers le soleil de la côte
ligurienne c'est une course historique
une course à la copie
voilà
les jeux sont faits copie ne sera pas
rejoint ni ce jour là ni les suivants il
a un avantage de 14 minutes sur
teisseire et de 24 minutes sur bartali
l'italie se divise entre procopi et pro
bartali
giraud 1946 un nouveau duel se prépare
fausto coppi souris et plaisante avec
ses équipiers gino bartali sous son
vieil air bourru est un homme sincère
la course n'est pas sans risque
non
sur la route qui mène à trieste
revendiquée par la yougoslavie
la caravane est attaqué par des bandits
armés incontrôlés
bartali qui suce la roue de copies
conserve le maillot rose
copé franchi la ligne d'arrivée en tête
lors de la dernière étape aux arènes de
milan mais disqualifié pour sprint
irrégulier
après tant d'heures de course copie
arrive secondes à une minute de son amie
et rivale
le tour d'italie 2009 147 se déroule en
pleine reconstruction
les routes sont précaires dans un pays
encore dévasté par la guerre où les
ruines sont des plaies ouvertes
après des kilomètres couverts de terre
de poussière et de sueur bartali coppi
sous les yeux de leurs admirateurs
s'apprête à disputer la grande course
tous les coureurs sont épuisés par les
montées éprouvante coppi et bartali
offre au contraire un spectacle
stupéfiant
copé toujours couchée sur son guidon et
la figure du piémont t introverti
bartali celle du toscan ronchonneurs
copie grimpe une croûte qui semble
facile sous la légèreté de son coup de
le panorama est à couper le souffle
l'effort de copies et constant mais
bartali ne faillit pas
first originaux sont en train d'écrire
une page de l'histoire du cyclisme
malgré le vent en sa défaveur le premier
arrive à 30 avec plus de quatre minutes
d'avancé sur le vieux
à l'arrivée bartali vaincus ne peut
cacher sa tristesse
nous sommes en pleine guerre froide le
14 juillet des néo-fascistes tirs sur le
secrétaire général du pc palmiro
togliatti le blessant de son lit
d'hôpital taulier qui calme les esprits
et rassure la population
ok là toutes les tailles
une fois
mais un homme en date l'expression les
gens à fait
il recèle t il recourir parfois de la
foule avait très vite à santa pola à
foulard sur vous et ses ventes et de
l'espoir et in fine aux italiens n'ont
pas fait notre boulot si vous aimez le
décor est hélas encore des services
canons et des régions de louga fatick
à
tél
et on soigne est évident il estime donc
la masseuse rêver et bon la vie m'a mis
là non on s'est retrouvé ce pas là la
matière en jeu qui à part sont achevées
sans ses complications
les ministres devront passer et ce car
s'ils continuent d consentis
peu
pourquoi
jean alary mans et la finesse de la
boule à fatiguer
je peux pas
brenders ou non les fatiguer télé
réalité10 quest régime dit de l'italien
nouvelle
le
m
et
nico vie il y aurait une forme
magnifique oui fourneaux maintenait la
photo c'est la tradition à l'école
le tour de france commence c'est la
première fois que coop y participent
mais il commence mal le cinquième jour
dans l'étape de saint malo il fut rien
de cassé mais son vélo est inutilisable
il a deux minutes de retard ce n'est
rien mais son moral en a pris un coup
bartali l'attend l'aide
copie arrive avec 35 minutes de retard à
saint malo il veut abandonner mais la
nuit porte conseil
et comme une horloge bien réparer la
machine humaine se remettent en match
sa position est parfait centre de
gravité impeccablement placé jambes
interminables qui donne à son coup de
un rythme correct et continue
résultat son retard se réduit à 15
minutes après le franchissement des
pyrénées
enfin les alpes
couverte de neige en hiver arrosé par
les puits en étaient elles sont envahies
de cars en juillet dans l'étape cannes
briançon le suisse ferdy kübler surnommé
le fou pédalant s'échappe comme une
flèche à 10 km de l'arrivée
doté d'une puissance phénoménale
il n'est toutefois pas un grand stratège
il
personne ne le suit mais une crevaison
le contraint à s'arrêter
barta les copies sont en tête d'un
groupe dont il se détache pour peu à peu
transformé la course en 1 2 l
les autres tous les autres ne sont plus
que des figurants à la dérive
à briançon copie ralenti pour laisser
passer par paris qui fête son 35e
anniversaire
il offre le maillot jaune à son ami gino
les deux italiens n'ont désormais plus
d'adversaires bartali préfère remporter
le grand prix de la montagne
ecopy savourer des victoires d'étapes en
plaine
au sommet du petit saint bernard non
loin de la frontière italienne
la distance qui les sépare du peloton
est trop importante pour qu'il soit
rejoint
don
dans la plaine sur la route d'aoste
copie peut être tranquille
c'est au tour de bartali de lever le
pied le campionissimo poursuit seul sa
course vers le territoire italien
copie revêt son premier maillot jaune
il remporte le tour il a gagné son pari
le héros est heureux
quatre jours plus tard c'est le dernier
contre-la-montre d'êtres humains il se
transforme en bolide le campionissimo
souris
bartali entre le premier au parc des
princes comme l'année précédente mais
copie même le tour avec une bonne avance
sur l'infatigable gino
copie à 30 ans il est à l'apogée de sa
carrière
c'est sa plus grande victoire une
victoire sur lui-même plus que sur ses
rivaux
nettali découvre sa passion pour les
engins à moteur
on
girard dingue beilun binda guen les
champions des années 1920-1930
quant à être là pour la dernière course
des années 1940 automne 1949 le tour de
lombardie démarre fausto coppi a
derrière lui une année de miracle
sportif troisième victoire au giro
première déclare au tour de france
maillot du championnat de poursuite
vainqueur au championnat d'italie sur
route
malgré cela il n'est pas fatigué pour la
quatrième fois consécutive
il se lance dans cette course et l'a
remporté dans son style habituel en
s'échappant il va jusqu'au pied du
visage et dans la plaine seul contre
tous il double les minutes avancent
qu'il a gagné dans la montagne
1950 9e étape du giro
il ya une centaine de participants des
106 ses chats une échappée folle sans
soutien tactique avec comme seul but
foncez il distance le peloton
les couvreurs sorte de prime olano
postaux copie est absent de l'équipe
bien qu il a une triple fracture du
bassin selon le diagnostic du médecin
pour copie non seulement le giro est
terminée mais aussi la saison qu'il
avait ouverte en remportant paris
roubaix et la flèche wallonne
contre le tennesse robic et le tout
jeune hugo koblet qui porte déjà le
maillot rose
il croit en bartali
jean on va sur ses 36 ans il commence à
attaquer véritablement ici sur le port
doit et le garder ma à bolzano
il réussit à s'en tirer avec une envolée
astucieuse mais le suisse est dans sa
roue le petit gobelet qui se peignent en
pédalant n'est pas un rigolo il le
démontrera en conservant le maillot rose
sans problème jusqu'à l'arrivée finale à
rome
1950 est déjà du passé
fausto coppi s'entraîne
consciencieusement avec son frère cers
le 29 juillet il participe au tour du
piémont pour mettre au point son coup de
n'aura pas ses soldats
ils ont compris ma vie en échec il ya
des victoires du news show est vivant et
jean haurat dispose aussi vite qu'avant
donc on a dream the polyphonic compliqué
il suffit de vivre aux mains des
compagnies s'y arrimer à progresser pour
la touraine rapport qu il prendrait
accompagnent l'histoire drac et
l'hôtellerie
côté démocrate on sait quand elle
répondait nasreddine maginot et
originaire il s est offert aux ménages
aux origines français de recoller et des
autres peuples et on est sur la piste de
l'ordre n'ont pas le faire contribuer
les primo dans l'internât rossello est
en cours
serse coppi meurt d'une hémorragie
cérébrale suite à une chute en ville qui
ne l'a pas empêché de franchir la ligne
d'arrivée
fausto est brisé il ne courra peut-être
plus le spectacle continue 11e étape du
tour de france brive agen
le boxeur ray sugar robinson est au
départ de la course
4 3 2 à part des plus gobelet que l'on
nomme le pédaleur de charme un déjà
remporté l'étape contre le monde
maintenant il s'échappe sur les faux
plats vers agen seul pendant 140 km un
exploit qu'à la copie qui en fait un
candidat à la victoire finale
on n'est pas encore dans les pyrénées où
fausto est le seul à lui résister mais
l'italien a traîné de force sur les
routes de france
il est totalement démoralisés et koblet
semble imbattable
le retard de cinq minutes qui l'accusent
ne représente pas grand chose car les
alpes sont encore devant lui mais
bientôt il a quarante minutes de retard
dans sa tentative de contenir une
nouvelle attaque de combler dans le tas
carcassonne montpellier copie n'en peut
plus il n'a jamais eu un coup de pompe
si grave de toute sa carrière
poussez soutenu par ses équipiers il
subit la france d'être hors temps
c'est l'époque du miracle économique
l'entrée de l'italie dans la communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier vaut
sans aucun doute le sacrifice de
l'immigration
koh lanta et la communité carbo
sidérurgique à ses collègues afin d'
j'appelle jo hollande en allemagne à un
symbole et italiens ils n'ont pas audio
mittal dernier prime
les gens de plus l'histoire aventuriers
plus que heroes l'on pourrait ainsi
définir le cyclisme les coureurs dont
les témoignages fans et par le temps qui
passe inexorablement ne sont pas entrées
dans le bagage culturel et sportif des
jeunes des dernières générations
les souvenirs les anecdotes les plus
croustillantes les événements les plus
poignants se perdent dans l'oubli on ne
sait pas ce qu'il ya derrière ce que les
pionniers du cyclisme ont voulu
transmettre à la postérité à nous qui
sommes seulement attirée par le
sensationnel
il est temps d'exprimer notre
reconnaissance à tous ces athlètes qui à
leur époque ont imprimé dans le coeur et
l'esprit des sportifs de magnifiques
sentiment alimentée par la passion pour
un sport dur qui demande un sacrifice
extraits
le cyclisme est entré dans la légende
parce qu'il a toujours été un sport
d'humbles presque tous les grands
champions sont issus des couches
sociales défavorisées et sont de vrais
fils du peuple
certains d'entre eux qui sont nés et ont
grandi dans des régions pauvres doivent
la fin de leur anonymat et leur gloire à
la bonne vieille bicyclette considéré
alors comme l'un des plus modestes
moyens de transport
milan san remo 1952 le vainqueur et
loreto petrucci outsider de l'équipe
bianchi
ce sont des personnages légendaires hors
du commun qui ont contribué à créer un
important mouvement de sympathie vers
une discipline facile à appréhender
instinctive et qui ne s'embarrasse pas
de trop de règles leur histoire est
truffé d'anecdotes incroyable de
péripéties paradoxalement amusante et
dramatique
elle retrace leurs manies leurs phobies
leur ardente passion le danger que
recèle la popularité
mais aussi l'amertume de la défaite les
terribles coups de pompe et le
découragement qui s'en suit
les rivalités les antipathies les
rapports difficiles entre les membres
d'une équipe souvent divisés par
l'exaltation propre sportif aujourd'hui
dit-on le cyclisme a changé la
succession rapide des prestations
exceptionnelles et des records a fini
par effacer l'aspect humain le sacrifice
les sentiments et l'âme des coureurs
au point qu'elle a gommé les histoires
émouvantes et extraordinaire des
protagonistes d'alors
ils étaient nombreux les prétendants au
maillot rose du giro 2009 152
l'indomptable bartali manie vainqueur du
giro en 1951
kugler maillot rose en 1950 gobelet qui
a remporté le giro en 1950 et la grande
boucle l'année suivante et au pied des
dolomites copie a déjà endossé le
maillot rose
quand de venise à bolzano le giro
attaque les dolomites copie domine
éliminant ses adversaires c'est à cet
endroit que fausto a remporté son
deuxième tour d'italie
ici il assure son troisième prions
dans les 100 premiers kilomètres son
équipe a su mais le peloton et fausto
attaque les failles sont très vite il
est seul
l'école du port deuil de sel ils courent
une épreuve contre la montre sur un
dénivelé de 12 13%
à l'arrivée à bolzano copier toujours
seul il a cinq minutes sur bartali et
manie si sûr kubler et géminiani qu'il a
voulu intégrer à son équipe un équipier
de luxe koblet est encore loin
les finalistes à tour à mal
l'équipier est un coureur qui se met
totalement au service du chef de file
poster vos péripéties de laetita prendre
le côté ya longtemps bien avant il
viendra les lombards et voilà notre foi
ont crié certains terminaux pour les
fournisseurs corps d'élite est manifeste
que la radio c'est qu'aucun autre fait
différente et renault mais elles m'ont
fait ainsi que pour la prochaine copa
série comique et pédalage qui vit se
regarder le nombril est offert à mon
sens c'est une excellent nom doux et
compterait primature est valable car il
faut le temps
il prévoit de l'énergie paris samedi
notre pierrot question la question est
ce qu'il me parle et elle a promis
alors quand le celi alors que cinq
différentes communautés mais je paye des
caisses près de 10% des primes au fait
qu'il allait pénaliser leur a dit que la
haine de l'autre et par région et notre
l'iceberg
le rêve impensable de carré amelot dure
15 jours
le tour de france 2009 152 en est à la
moitié et les coureurs affrontent les
virage abrupt de l'ap d'huez
copie et troisième classement général il
a déjà hypothéqué le tour dans le
contre-la-montre à nancy gêné par les
sprints de robic il se décide à passer à
l'action et remporte le maillot jaune
que revêtait carré à halle
seul robin s'est accroché à sa roue
le breton est un battant il a un courage
immense et tenace
où
non
ils endorment d'agok d'oise un sk tâte
la tap à pied de la digue ouest autour
du calaisis pris ma catégorie après
couilles de john dario galli et être de
retour le 10 secondes alors dit m
et face à la multiplication de l'automne
est là que la prime à chi l'ha à la pac
de la croix de fer sous d'une tentative
de la sono stati copie géminiani et
l'espagnol albert illera paix le conseil
maître de l'air à l'équilibré au maquis
coloscopie ils copient des grandes
forces
il présente une classe
vivolta car les choses paraissaient pas
tout bord et campoli simon capuche et
que l'on grimpe à ramallah selon guo
linna j'ai bien aimé la belle est gravé
dans la mariage à la croix que la battle
où ils ont tiré partout si je faire
deviner de quoi le rythme kassadin faire
ma commune à mahdia bartali ils baissent
que le résultat est juste hommage dallas
est un podium est géré par yann que son
parti d'origine de l'outil va de
générateurs le film fera pas aux tâches
l'avs est mis la pression et une entente
entre les dix nouvelles écopes essayé
sur golf hier après midi quarante
secondes de moins que son contrat ne
mentionne que les joueurs et des tapis
doré est partout solana a confirmé
richard
à 8h et 9h à 18h
maintenant selon lequel ces comptes de
cole d'été matelassé galibier ecopy
territoire parlant des tours à la salle
ita 34 rifi de kilomètres les candidats
le décoincer 2000 à madrid il raconta
doit ni la chine guo changqing quant à
sa femme tabiou forte de la montagne
lundi belles espérances et des gens le
gui est insolite facile par la dépouille
mais aucun des deux avantages elle joue
à plein
hayward a tant d'histoire geminiani et
son petit nom psa cadarsi qu'on a
l'ivresse casino
l'accord des sociétés cinq semaines au
total recall et du sénat et on a beau
dire on arrivait de l'écologie qui
restent et copines elles seules entrées
quaranta ce qu'on dit de ban avec la
swing tshimanga l'évier qu'ecolo belle à
disparaître sd tandis qu'anthony et
yttrium présidentielle j
lâchez pas
les accords geminiani connais assez gros
gelabert protagonistes pourrait comparer
les facois décisive à l'espace
talatamaty david herrero expliqué jeudi
que sur le canton et granby ma coiffeuse
en cavale
position de la tête et gino bartali ses
calculs de laisser guider par autre
chose
sous le gui
nous sommes fiers de la corse est pour
sa part n'espère année la révélation de
journée la canadien repose sa rivale
cervélo paris almdt elodie pakosz ferry
aurait grand maistre qui est quatre
hôpitaux là et louise non
un beau panorama des alpine evangela
butinage digitalisation de la base de
quantico lima qui a donné alpes est un
privilège auquel s'oppose le dominateur
du bourg de montagne n'importe quel
serait il
pour les dalton
mais hors myditto lucky uke dans l'arène
olivier mes copines ville
souvent souriant sont à la rivalité
encore autour de cette tendance
des pro bells beach halde comme tout à
kalma où la banane est ici de carburant-
benzema shalit
il continuera
la possible machine à des copies prodigy
nature non par de gaulle
mabiala sa part expliqué la présidente
de la cellule
vas-y mobile c'est à ce quartier aux
contorsions 18 et le manioc phénomène
atlantique vendée cyclisme italien est
présidé par antoine tanguay sopra tous
nos produits qu'elle se distille le
démontrent les copies dans le monde elle
confine italien eddy king saud seysses
bartali coppi et prennent d'assaut la
salle italien
la ville à l'état de noël dans la
journée quand bbio pas bouger tellement
ils passent au décor pilpa souk el ghazi
ben ali a sonné le dominateur et année
la victoria coren jamais mardi prochain
au décolleté loisel et se permettait des
minorités est pas qu il cesse bière la
vision et de la magnifique alors et
alpina b5 on est bien préparé les gens
commencent goldberg et cole baird était
l'un de ses collaborateurs sur le sujet
lors qu'ils aient une graine de capital
alors que l'équipe est au tour
à sa manière les comptes des douze
civils est très surveillée
m
ridoret
j'attends j'espère qu'elle est belle
normal et d'une carte graphique
napolitano est en effet un des dix jours
la victoire du lobby nino malapet
république s'apprête à paris place de
janeiro sao paulo et d'ignorer
dans le parc des princes jeudi 25 à 30
mètres de tour quaranta villa
personnelle
une télécopie maîtresse a perdu sa mère
sera branché de miami la religion ni
nationalité
eric sti 2d donc les joies de la famille
des choses les formes ovales benallou
d'alternance est il trop de copies
nautisme et procurations de la victoire
l'athlète a battu tous aller vers la
tribune d'honneur
adacore éléments de la personnalité de
la mafia italienne et de la fédération
internationale
et
on
la loi s'il y en a l'art chinois hu
jintao et l'ouest avait pas de prime non
solum margot loup et to this way
compagne
oh
le giro de 1953 est dominé par koblet
copie à presque 34 ans sur les dolomites
il a opté pour la force mais comblé la
rejoint dans la longue descente vers
bolzano et l'a clairement laissé
remporté l'étape lors du sprint
en contrepartie il certains ce que
copine lui livrent pas bataille le
lendemain dans l'étape du stelvio
ce soir-là à bolzano koblet est
convaincu d'avoir gagné son deuxième
tour d'italie
fausto est résigné il a deux minutes de
retard au classement général
dans les premiers virages du stelvio le
peloton arrive épuisé les équipiers de
copies sont allés à un train d'enfer à
bormio il a presque quatre minutes
d'avancé sur koblet c'est ainsi que
coppi arrache sa cinquième victoire du
giro
1955 tour d'italie copie cours dans
l'espoir de le remporter il le perdra à
13 secondes
même les dolomites ne pénalise pas
gastone nencini il est maillot rose
lorsque la caravane entame les premiers
kilomètres de l'avant dernière étape 30
san pellegrino l'histoire du giro
semblent terminés
copie remporte l'étape et manier la
course
le tour de lombardie clôt la saison
cycliste 1956
copé avait conquis ni dans sa roue peut
être une échappée du ghisallo à la
périphérie de milan rejoint il tente de
vaincre lors du sprint mais il perd
juste derrière darrigade
au vélodrome 2 vigorelli de milan est
recoller baldini jeune étoile montante
s'envole littéralement et remporte le
record de l'heure 1957 dans la galerie
victor emmanuel à milan la foule à six
autres faits baraki un contre la montre
à 2 le couple est recalé baldini fausto
coppi est en compétition avec un stylet
darrigade
ce sera la dernière victoire de coppi
en 1958 dans la péninsule la bicyclette
n'est plus trop à l'ordre du jour
ans
nous sommes dans l'italie du boom
économique des vacances et du cerceau
qui fait se déhancher des gamines sur la
plage
le cas puisque le semble descendre sur
les grands héros du cyclisme
le 10 janvier 1960
fausto coppi le campionissimo meurent
avec lui se referme le livre du grand
cyclisme celui de la nostalgie du
courage et des pauvres
avec en arrière-plan les duels bartali
coppi
l'italie est sortie de la guerre et
s'est lancé dans le boom économique
embrassant la modernité
l'industrialisation et la civilisation
de masse au milieu des années 50
pendant les tours de france d'italie
entre 5 heures et 6 heures de l'après
midi à l'entrée des cafés on accrochait
d'immenses feuille de papier où était
écrit à la main l'ordre d'arrivée des
coureurs dans l'étape du jour les noms
de coppi et bartali était écrit en grand
on repassait 3 froid sur les lettres si
d'autres coureurs avaient gagné un seul
trait de crayon suffisait lorsque le
patron du bar afficher les résultats
les applaudissements fusent et et les
voitures s'arrêtaient c'était l'heure de
fermeture des bureaux et du changement
des équipes dans les usines les enfants
allaient attendre leur père à l'arrêt du
tram aujourd'hui il ne reste de tout
cela que de la nostalgie